the Joe Rogan experience for the the you
know Tesla's are there there's such cool
cars and they're such you know there's
such like you said serene you know what
I mean and all uh not I don't want to
give that credit exclusively to Tesla
because other V's provide a similar
experience to but the one place they're
lacking for the amount of money they
charge their interiors are a little
poems ask me if I'm getting one of those
trucks bro good luck ask me if I'm going
well the truck you get it yeah why you
askin course I'm get one of them trucks
yeah look at that thing you don't like
it no you don't like it no I don't I
don't like it and I how dare you I'm not
entirely sure it's it's real I mean I
think I've seen I think my initial
reaction to that was that's not a real
thing meet George Jetson and my second
reaction is I'm pretty sure they
couldn't build and sell that in America
why that because I I just I just don't
think that that will pass the test that
it needs to pass and I and furthermore
like crash tests pedestrian safety stuff
like that furthermore it's it's it's
because how do I say this without it's
really hard to talk about Tesla because
their fans are [ __ ] crazy that they
get really mad and they don't leave me
alone in the beginning I thought that
it's complete [ __ ] and fake and a
fraud I've talked to sin a few people
since in the design space who design
cars professionally for a living and I
have been convinced that it could be
possible to build and sell a shape of
vehicle shaped sort of like that
although not exactly like that okay
having said that I think that the way
that it has been marketed is not
entirely honest
people company show concept cars all the
time right
there's nothing wrong with showing a
concept car there's nothing wrong with
going here's a here's a prototype we
built and this is going to show the
direction of our industry right and if
you build electric cars as your business
it's pretty easy to build a concept car
that runs and drives because you've got
your skateboard and you can just gonna
put any body on it right so odds are
there's like a Model X chassis
underneath that prototype truck right
but there's a one I don't think that
accepting reservations is an honest
thing to do when you don't know how
you're gonna build the truck don't know
there's no way that trucks on the road
next year no way not as I'm supposed to
I don't know in the road he did he said
20 he said next year 2021 20 21 23 full
3 motor 500 range badass one is like a
three year down the line things but
here's the problem building cars and
warranting them repairing them selling
them is like a logistics business
they're operating this company like a
tech company where it runs on hype like
where's the roadster that's supposed to
come out this year oh no I haven't seen
anything about it since I guess I don't
know that's the point
I don't like they've had these product
launches and they drilled up the hype it
juices the stock they take the
reservations but then it's like but you
have to deliver the product guys you're
you're actually a car company you're not
you're not exclusively driven on hype
but they have made some cars of course
no of course they made your there's one
here yeah yes no I'm not saying they
don't build and sell cars they build and
sell cars but what I am saying is their
business model is not like the regular
car companies in that it is so dependent
on this hype machine bringing in new
investors bringing in new reservation
cash when they go here's this crazy
Total Recall space truck and all it's
gonna cost you people to buy into my
space truck vision is $100 refundable
and you're not gonna find out if that
hundred dollars gets you a truck for
like two and a half years are you gonna
go after your $100 if he's late or it's
your
but I'm not saying you shouldn't buy
whatever he sells isn't the roaster
thing a different deal though don't you
have to pay all the money or something
there is a reservation process is all
I'm saying like the roaster thing was
different though low-key that requires a
substantial sum of money right but we
don't we haven't seen any roadsters
either we saw the prototype yeah but
it's easy to build a prototype when
you're Tesla Tesla can build a prototype
very easily they've got an electric
skateboard they can put any body on it
it'll look and feel like a mostly
running driving car let's say here forty
five thousand five thousand dollar
credit card payment plus forty five
thousand our wire transfer due in 10
days yeah so you gotta put up $50,000 so
here's giving him a zero interest loan
of $50,000 until he delivers this
product which is like a good income for
a lot of people free yeah give it up
correct and so I'm not saying that they
don't build and sell real cars I'm not
saying you shouldn't buy one or lease
one
I am saying and this goes for let's
let's expand this I'm not this isn't a
dig at Elon or Tesla specifically let's
talk about all cars don't pay for
something that isn't then handed to you
mmm there's no real ons a billionaire
why do you need to give him a zero
interest loan of $50,000 for a roadster
why do you need to give him a zero in
just a lot of $100 for a truck that he
hasn't demonstrated he could build yet
why do you think they made the roaster
50 grand and the down payment for the
truck only a hundred bucks because I
will tell you why because why I bill I
believe I believe I'm gonna I'm gonna
put this and I believe okay okay
I believe it's so they could go to a
bank or a VC because if it's only $100
you get you get so many the [ __ ] right
what five hundred thousand orders go
I've got two hundred and fifty thousand
orders
I need a billion dollars that's why you
would do that please look here's the
problem is if if it's legitimate okay if
it's all on the up-and-up if everything
is on the up and up there's a lot of
individual pieces that don't freely add
up right and on a house that's not made
of you know it's like imagine the
mortgage crisis Inouye you took all
these bad mortgages and you put them
together and all of a sudden it's
considered a good and that
right so he smashed the [ __ ] window
onstage he quoted a bunch of power and
torque figures that are basically made
up he did that dumb video with tug of
war the f-150 that was completely fake
that is a fake the f-150 was in
two-wheel drive and he was towing it
uphill that's not like if you gonna make
it easier for the car a drawer of
downhill and uphill it no towing uphill
well it would be the weight transfer is
is if you have a two-wheel drive pickup
truck going downhill my friend Jason
Fenske to engineering explained did a
whole video explaining debunking this
but if you have an all-wheel drive
extremely heavy vehicle because let's be
honest if they build that truck that's a
65 hundred pound vehicle steel and
batteries all-wheel-drive
versus a pickup truck that's put into
two-wheel drive with no weight in the
bed right that's just so it's like all
automakers make up silly games to show
up their product right their tow the
space shuttle or whatever [ __ ] they
do right but they make up a game they
know they can win they don't make up a
game and then cheat at it like why are
you gonna do a tug of war video if you
then have to cheat at the video on video
to do it like pick a different game you
know you can win what kind of a person
makes up a game and then cheats at it
like that's just the air Ford wanted to
get one of their own they're like well
why don't you give us one of your
Tesla's yes dude and then somebody up it
up at the top said don't engage that
idiot what are you doing I'm not doing
this yeah I so look again well they
probably can't look realistically it
can't really compete with it I think not
it's not a test of anything it's a test
of weight and tire grip that's it but
when you truck I realize it's a thing
they do truck let's bring them let's
bring that cyber truck over to a gravel
pit and dump two tons of dread did you
see any like of the renderings of people
like camping in the cyber truck looks
absurd well yeah it's just like dude
like he went to [ __ ] you know you
want to buy one
wait till he says this is the one you
can buy I never put order and yeah I
just I don't think what I don't think
box congratulations you just bought into
the scam that's that's that's you know
what I mean I seem like I don't think
it's like a full-on fraud I just think
he's figured out creative ways to to get
the public to bankroll [ __ ] yeah that he
already said was done bro a million robo
taxis by 2020 where's the Robo taxis bro
Zoey said yeah this cyber truck thing
came out of seemingly nowhere but right
kind of at the same time that they
figured out that full self-driving is
not right around the corner as they said
it was it's a lot of backtracking going
on in the full self-driving level-5 is
not coming anytime soon you're not gonna
be able to send your Tesla out to do
errands for you without a driver in it
anytime soon what was the parking with
Tesla promises 1 million robo taxis yeah
that was from 2019 for yeah for tonight
I mean technically they have a year in a
month left but they have delivered zero
Robo taxis he did he said that [ __ ] man
yeah but problem with Tesla is Elon says
some [ __ ] that then is impossible and
then they have to figure out how to do
it later and sometimes doesn't work do
you know who Kyle Dunnigan is no who's
that one of the funniest guys alive but
he's got the best Instagram on the
planet and he does face swaps uh-huh
uuugh now that you know you didn't
answer the deep fat guy know he does a
lot well doctor fakin Stein's newest one
give me some volume on this give me some
volume on this and go to fullscreen yeah
oh my god
how creepy yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] oh great
idea lon
do it again today window same ball you
should go differently [ __ ] [ __ ] now i
mark zuckerberg is officially cooler
than you know i'm cooler i make rockets
that's cool
well i connect the world to facebook i'm
I'm double Kula double but I'm infinity
oh my god 30 plus one that's one more
cooler you can't add anything to
infinity you've only a nerd who's uncool
would know that ha ha very uncool this
is too many all the data and I found
this invention you unveiled in high
school so so its senses you feel getting
a boner and then deploys this over you
letting everyone know you don't have a
boner so it's pretty cool pretty cool I
know I could use this at Miss Tinsley
scars ha ha ha she's got great boobs
Draper's not Tinsley crap it's [ __ ]
weird that smashing the glass is one of
the was one of the greatest moments in
automotive history I was laying in bed
and my wife was next to me asleep and I
have nowhere why did they think that
they could do that I don't know there's
I know the same idea was that when they
hit the wall or hit the door with the
hammer that it broke the glass or no
that first they didn't the door with a
sledgehammer they did that but except he
was using an orange hammer which is a
dead blow hammer not a sledgehammer so
that's a little disingenuous deadblow
yeah it's designed to not dent things
it's assigned to hit things without
stretching rubber yes but still who said
two windows were a regular Tesla door
probably because they're aluminum but
not a stainless steel panel right I
wouldn't tend to stainless steel panel
and then he goes the windows are
bulletproof it's steel Paul right then
he puts up a video the next day that's
like oh here was us testing it right
before the reveal word actually did show
that it worked before why did it work
how do you know the video was made
before and not after after they fixed it
there's a shop-vac on the floor and a
towel over the door as if you had just
cleaned up a bunch of broken glass
that's true yeah go look at the video
there's a shop vac on the floor with a
hose laid out like right underneath the
door
[Music]
yeah that's true
owls over a door kind of maybe if you
would just smashed a bunch of glass out
of it that is a dope looking car I don't
give a [ __ ] what anybody thinks
I don't ask well I'm glad you don't
carry things and if they make that I
will be extend can I just bring up what
is the word cyber like cool now yes like
cyber was exclusively cool for like the
last 15 years ago again very cool very
cool
only nerds only a real nerd wouldn't
know the cyber is cool cool plus one
[ __ ] hell it's so silly
[Applause]